right now
many americans have to be vaccinated
against the covet virus or they were not
allowed to teach or they're not allowed
to work in a hospital yet the two
million people that are coming across
the border there's no requirement that
they be tested or there's no requirement
that they be vaccinated
so the united states of all countries in
the world at its very founding have the
idea that you
could become an american if you cross
the borders and you accepted the
american idea so when people came from
diverse countries
they had skills they spoke english and
they came legally and there was not
whole blocks
of ethnic castes that had grievances or
they had
difficulties in assimilation with the
majority population and more importantly
legal immigration was welcome because it
kind of reminded americans that there
were people who were very competitive
and they wanted this system of free
market economics constitutional
government a bill of rights that was
lacking in their home country what
happens when the host
itself i.e the united states has lost
confidence in its traditions and customs
and doesn't feel
that it should or has a right or it
wouldn't be nice to impose their values
on people who are arriving across a
border then immigration turns from
something very desirable and positive
to something that can be very pernicious
and dangerous the corporate
establishment has been a big
advocate of open borders
and it's been very hard to write op-eds
for the wall street journal or talk to
the chamber of commerce because they
feel that immigration even if it's
illegal is very good for their own
bottom line and the democratic party
said if you come illegally we will
ensure that you will not be subject to
the enforcement of immigration laws we
will provide you with entitlements but
we expect in exchange
fealty and loyalty and fidelity at the
polls and it explains right why now we
do not
enforce immigration law because too many
parties have too many vested interests
and we look at the border
and it is a construct it doesn't exist
in reality people are simply walking
across and you have people coming in
vast numbers from one direction they do
not speak english they're not legal and
we the host are not the hosts that we
have been from the prior 280 years but
we feel diffident lack of confidence
about our own system we don't feel we
want to impose on our new visitors we
feel it would be cultural appropriation
to tell them that this system is better
than the one they're leaving you add all
of that up and you have chaos
and the erosion of the idea of
citizenship
[Music]
you